[Musique]
ambiance festive sur le stand de la
réunion
le séga résonne dans les allées du
pavillon outre-mer du salon de
l'agriculture
[Musique]
le salon a ouvert ses portes le 25
février et ce lundi marque
l'inauguration du village agricole
réunionnais un village qui comme chaque
année vient promouvoir la filière
agricole et les savoir-faire pays chaque
année on est présent et on fait même
partie je dirais de l'histoire même du
salon puisque historiquement la chambre
d'agriculture est toujours présente avec
un ensemble de partenaires parmi ces
partenariats le conseil départemental
qui est aussi notre notre financeur il
ya le syndicat du sucre de la réunion
y aller la réunion tourisme pour la
promotion du tourisme à la réunion et
une dizaine d'exposants agriculteurs et
transformateurs qui sont autour du stand
de l'île de la réunion sur le site sur
le le village agricole ce qu'on appelle
nous les villages agricoles sur les
stands du salon les productions leader
de l'île sont représentés comme la canne
à sucre les fruits les épices et la
vanille mais aussi les produits
transformés rome confitures huiles
essentielles en tout ce sont 15 tonnes
de produits réunionnais qui ont été
acheminés jusqu'à paris chaque jour
juste en prend un vrai plaisir à faire
goûter aux visiteurs ses membres et
ananas victoria y en a qui font de la
maladie relativement banal
la nausée du pitaya et puis l'on gagne
ici on l'avait emmené et le titre danone
mignonne qui est très très bon à manger
on amène du soleil ou domaine de la
couleur c'est bon ça sent bon bah je dis
c'est on apporte un petit bout de la
réunion de la couleur chez nous voilà la
maison isautier présente pour la
deuxième année consécutive sur le salon
pour l'entreprise
l'objectif est d'être au plus près des
consommateurs il y avait une
méconnaissance du produit sur le grand
public et ce salon les salons les salons
en général grand public
c'est une très belle vitrine
effectivement pour promouvoir le produit
de la réunion sur la métropole
donc pour nous c'est un créneau qui
reste trade qui est très très
intéressant chaque année le salon
accueille 700 mille visiteurs dont 100
mille professionnels des professionnels
qui constitue une partie de la clientèle
de willy spécialisée dans la vanille ça
fait la quatrième année qu'on est sur ce
récent de la culture c'est le seul salon
confort métropole pour la vanille c'est
indispensable
90 % de la clientèle vanille ca produits
haut de gamme et celles qui ont tels que
touristique s'il clients étaient
métropolitaine et européennes s'y est à
nous dirons que c'est pas la peine mais
si on veut avoir une vision à moyen
terme et avoir une filière qui se tient
pour dix ans et fille est ici on
comptait les métropolitains qui viennent
à la réunion
les gens qui sont venus à la réunion qui
sont ici de bouche à oreille
après aussi on a une nouvelle clientèle
et des épiceries fines
c'est les pâtissiers c'est le grand
cuisinier donc c'est une porte ouverte
vers ces métiers là là ces gens là et
donc ça nous donne encore plus de force
pour augmenter notre production et pour
encourager nos producteurs
lors de l'inauguration du village
réunionnais la présidente du conseil
départemental et le vice président en
charge de l'agriculture étaient présents
l'occasion pour eux de rappeler toute la
richesse de la production réunionnaise
et de réaffirmer leur soutien à la
filière agricole
c'est un moment incontournable je pense
que pour faire connaître l'agriculture
et faire connaître les produits de nos
agriculteurs
notre présence est indispensable il nous
faut absolument accompagner la chambre
et culture mais également l'ensemble des
exposants dans leur présence ici
hier à paris et le département le
conseil départemental est l'un des
acteurs partenaires de cette
manifestation avec notamment liberté la
chambre et culture et nous tenons à être
présent chaque année pour confirmer
notre soutien au monde agricole de la
réunion
c'est une vitrine qui me permettrait de
faire venir également des touristes à la
réunion puisqu'il vient aujourd'hui un
vrai potentiel sur le tourisme culinaire
et il ya les bons produits de la bonne
terre et puis j'ai envie aussi de la
voix de cuisine dont c'est aussi une
manière de faire connaître et la réunion
s'est produit la terre française de
l'océan indien
autour du village plusieurs espaces de
restauration permettent de découvrir la
gastronomie réunionnaise
cédric s'active en cuisine il doit gérer
chaque jour 300 couverts au menu
aujourd'hui rougail saucisses rougail zf
massalé le cabri et boucané on a un
métissage qui est énorme
le couple sûr qu'ils aient l'idée c'est
de mettre en avant tous à la petite
rennaise sais c'est que ça ça mélange de
plusieurs cultures et au final ça se
ressent dans le goût cantons et
demi-cantons ont confirmé en gc ca
nicolas s'est installé à table
originaire de la réunion il a posé un
jour de congé pour se replonger dans ses
racines c'est important oui de mettre en
avant la réunion mais l'ensemble des dom
au niveau de la métropole parce que bon
on a tendance à oublier que la france
est aussi à l'autre bout du monde et à
la réunion entre autres états quand même
un pays à venir découvrir et j'invite
tout le monde à venir faire un tour à la
réunion en plus du village et des stands
de délégation de 40 agriculteurs ont
fait le déplacement pour un voyage
d'étude
ils viennent échanger avec les
professionnels de la filière et
découvrir les dernières avancées
techniques
à noter également que cette année le
miel litchi de la réunion participe au
concours général agricole
les cinquante quatrième salon
international de l'agriculture se
poursuit jusqu'au 5 mars au parc des
expositions de paris et lille
intensément agricole où vous y attend
[Musique]